bonjour à toutes et à tous bonjour
michel lui linda bonjour boucher caruge
bonjour aux auditeurs de martinique
bonjour à la population achète chez un
particulier à saint pierre vous êtes
trésorier de l'est républicain de
martinique donc du parti elle erre ici
alors la présidence de l air a été
renouvelé le week-end dernier ça y'est
christian jacob a été élu à la
présidence de l'est républicain le
week-end dernier qu'est ce que cela
change au sein de la section
territoriale de martigny croix c'est le
musicien christian jacob a démontré
qu'il est un rassembleur et
qu'aujourd'hui il a une forte expérience
dans le syndicalisme agricole il a eu
quand même des portefeuilles
ministériels donc défini des ministères
importants donc aujourd'hui il est le
chantier est grand
aujourd'hui je dis souvent que l'outil
il est performant nous avons un
rassembleur il a démontré qu'il est
rassembleur puisque c'est pas pour les
queens qu'il a été qu'il est maintenant
qu il est vrai toujours it et président
du groupe à l'assemblée nationale dont
des officiers c'est important mais comme
vous m'avez tendu la perche au niveau
des élections je voudrais adresser un
message de remerciement à tous les
électeurs et des électrices des
républicains pour avoir participé de
manière massive à cette élection qui est
importante parce que aujourd'hui élire y
compris chez nous en martinique
situation vous méditant ce
renouvellement
je reçois une fédération nous avons sans
cette fédération et nous avons un siège
et aujourd'hui il est important de
donner la parole aux adhérents
c'est un exercice de démocratie et vous
savez nous aux républicains nous sommes
une grande famille très sensible la
démocratie vous avez déjà les résultats
ici le suit en martinique et ont voté
massivement en faveur de christian jacob
aujourd'hui la haute autorité c'est une
structure qui effectivement qui est la
peau organisée et équilibrée et résultat
transparent et aujourd'hui christian
jacob a été vraiment établie dans sa
fonction il est maintenant le président
des républicains
vous aimez les sorties en tête ici on a
fini les gentils antennes d'une vente
uniquement lorsque haut niveau au niveau
des résultats n'a
ronald et les sorties à 60 2 % ça fait à
peu près 60 6000 électeurs qui ont voté
pour lui aux 130 et 133 milles et en
martinique nous avons 207 207 électeurs
et il est sorti avec une large majorité
très bien alors christian jacob qui
succède donc à laurent wauquiez 1 qui
avait démissionné il va il y a quelques
mois christian jacob qui était très
proche d'ailleurs de feu l'ex-président
de la république jacques chirac eux et
donc certains dit justement que c'est
une tonalité plus chiraquienne qui
revient un peu à la tête de ce parti par
rapport à laurent wauquiez qui crispe
est ici ou là y compris ceux quelques
militants de l air laurent wauquiez a
montré des qualités effectivement dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions et même en
venant présenter sa démission je parlais
de crispation moins de trois espèces
saisies qui la contrôle les cafés
terrasses et ça c'est le passé
aujourd'hui nous avons un homme
christian jacob qui est rassembleur et
qui aujourd'hui vingt on a besoin de
rassembler et oui parce qu'elle est
municipale qui revient d'ailleurs on y
vient parce que nous n'avons pas
beaucoup de temps michel unis dès les
municipales le chantier des municipales
comment comment se prépare-t-elle ici
pour vous pour lr martinique que nous
sommes ne sommes partis politiques
réactif et nous sommes sur le terrain à
tout moment nous avons des délégués de
circonscription qui d'autre chaque
circonscription qui fait un travail
qu'ils font des réunions qui nous
propose des candidats et sur l'ensemble
des des communes
nous aurons des candidats puisque le
discours des républicains se disent qu
basé sur la démocratie mais surtout
basés sous la responsabilité parce que
je pars du possible que moi aujourd'hui
les républiques et nous faisons de la
politique nous ne le font pas de manière
affective
nous ne font pas de manière amicale nous
le faisons de manière un responsable
parce que les défis sont grands
les dossiers sont grands donc quand on
fait les choses avec responsabilité
on va effectivement plus dans
l'efficacité alors justement
l'occupation municipal s'ils ont pu dire
qui s'est réduite à peau de chagrin pour
l heure il ya qui ne dispose plus que
d'une copine d'une commune
enfin j'entends en tant que maire coince
donc c'est fred michel terrot d'ailleurs
le président de la leyre martinique qui
est mère au saint-esprit donc il s'agira
dans un premier temps sera peut-être
votre principale priorité c'est de
conserver justement saint-esprit très
bien moi je dis souvent qu'il faut de la
pédagogie il faut pas rappeler qu'il
faut rappeler que les élections
municipales
on ne va pas élire en mer c'est une
action de liste on va élire un conseil
même conseil municipal et ce conseil
municipal va élire au à son saint omer
et c'est pour ça qu effectivement nous
avons peut-être un seul maire qui fait
un travail excellent mais nous avons
énormément de deux républiques et qui
sont qui sont dans les conseiller dans
les conseils municipaux et qui participe
également à la vie des communes mais qui
participe aux décisions et donc et on
comprend bien que le discours de
responsabilité on vient conjuguer avec
ceux qui sont l'âme dans la majorité
alors donc je le disais il s'agira de
pouvoir éventuellement conserver cet
esprit
et puis de regagner aussi des
dépositions ici ou là dans une ancienne
place forte de la droite martiniquaise
un des leurs avant à portée de main
c'était effectivement le rpr ou au même
du temps de nicolas sarkozy avait encore
quelques communes qui était donc je
dirais bien représentée avec les
républicains et donc là où est ce que
vous mettez l'accent quelles communes
visées par exemple saint-joseph jeu cf
nausicaa miasmes est pressenti pour être
là pour gagner sauf justement comment ça
se passe les investitures sont déjà
adonnés la commission d'investiture ne
s'est pas encore penché à nous avons
effectivement des candidats républicains
sur ba soit dans un avant soumaré go
nous avons sur sur nous sur le marais
nous avons effectivement sur l'ensemble
des des communes là aujourd'hui la
commission d'investiture va se pencher
sur sept dossiers et avec en
collaboration avec tout le monde puisque
nous sommes la peau la recherche du
consensus
on va déterminer le candidat qui a le
profil
ça c'est l'échéance c'est combien de
suicides tout ça sera
d'ici un mois deux mois nous travaillons
pas dans la précipitation nous avons
déjà des décisions vont tomber assez
rapidement et vous aurez les éléments
nécessaires pour construire votre votre
schéma des politiques très bien alors ce
qui agite aussi beaucoup les
républicains depuis quelques temps c'est
le positionnement aller sur le curseur
de l'échiquier politique français plus
ou moins adroits quoi alors certains
sont tentés par une rapprochement du 2
et rennes du rassemblement national
dirigé par marine le pen et puis
d'autres ont déjà fait d'ailleurs le
saut 20 sont allés rejoindre les rangs
des manuels macron bon voilà le centre
ou le centre droit comme comme on voudra
mais enfin voilà et donc est ce qu en
martinique il ya aussi ce tiraillement
quelque chose c'est que vous évoquez si
c'est l'histoire
aujourd'hui l'avenir c'est avec
christian jacob le bureau politique va
statuer
hélas aujourd'hui va définir
effectivement légales et politiques
mais les grandes décisions pour les
alliances eux partout sur la france et
dans les territoires d'outre-mer
donc là aujourd'hui nous sommes
effectivement des républicains vous vous
pourriez trouver vous serez d'accord
vers un rapprochement de rn par exemple
rassemblement national et même à titre
personnel vous aux militants mais aussi
cadres dirigeants devront pas venir
comme ça faire des alliances puisque
nous savons tous que sur le territoire
de la martinique
les élèves vont présenter des candidats
contre les républicains
donc aujourd'hui comprenez bien que nous
avons un discours clair et tandis que
les rmc c'est quand même un petit un
petit cassoulet donc vous parler de
rassembler nationale ou la république en
marche où les deux finalement la
république en marche la république en
marche et le rassemblement national
qu'elle est non à la vente actions
ah ben voilà c'était ça le non non non
non non non vous pas question de
la démocratie ne sommes pas là pour nous
en cave et nous sommes là encore nous
nous sommes là encore pour conjuguer
avec tout le monde parce que nous
recherchons le consensus et la
responsabilité
ouais dernière question michel linda en
tant que responsable politique mais
aussi citoyen de martinique la sécurité
le sentiment d'insécurité la violence la
jeunesse enfin tout tout tout tout ce
débat là de tickets qui agite un peu
notre société
et puis le chlordécone aussi en ce
moment est-ce que c'est des sujets dont
vous vous entend pas beaucoup là dessus
sur des sur ces sujets de société la la
c'est vous à l'ère martin la sécurité
c'est appartient à la france le
ministère régalien à l'intérieur et là
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est au ministère de
l'intérieur la france 2 proposait à des
décisions et on a vu effectivement que
les policiers sont montés au créneau qui
a un malaise mais je pense que la
sécurité ça n'a pas explosé comme ça
depuis des années il y avait un malaise
et tout le monde savait que la bombe
allait exploser
bon aujourd'hui nous sommes devant un
schéma il faut aujourd'hui se mettre
autour d'une table pour trouver les
solutions au niveau du tour des codes
je rappelle que les gués public et nous
avons organisé une conférence où le
cours d'école aussi bien au niveau
scientifique avec madame sur ce village
mais également au niveau juridique avec
un homme qui maîtrise parfaitement le
développement durable et l'environnement
l'eau pour l'heure et qui se passe c'est
que la science effectivement reconnaît
le chlordécone
mais aucun juge ne va déterminer pour
dire oui il ya une cause de code ou
l'effet de causalité n'est pas n'est pas
n'existe pas mais aujourd'hui soyons
vigilants nous ne vont pas
instrumentaliser ce scandale sanitaire
ah ça veut dire quoi vous soutenez quand
même la démarche de la commission d
enquête parlementaire c'est président
j'ai présidé par le député c'est très
bien si aujourd'hui au début nous avons
senti il y avait des personnes
associations qui ont sensibilisé et
aujourd'hui les parlementaires prennent
ce dossier en main c'est qu'aujourd'hui
il faut aller plus loin et il faut
qu'aujourd'hui vous soutenez la démarche
ça mais bien sûr voilà il faut conclure
merci michel linder d'avoir participé à
ça au caddie bonne journée